it's no surprise when film goers
complain about the complete lack of
creativity coming from the movie
industry still if there's one thing even
worse than a lack of creativity it's too
much creativity and Hollywood's history
of insane abandoned sequel ideas proves
it since we're talking about planned
sequels be aware of spoilers for films
you haven't seen yet you'd think a
franchise with 200 million years a
backstory would have no problem coming
up with plots nevertheless the Jurassic
Park franchise has been hyper focused on
bio engineered super dinos the big bad
in Jurassic world was the indominus rex
basically a t-rex with various other
dinosaur DNA while Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom featured the Indo Raptor a
raptor crossed with the indominus rex
DNA believe it or not it could have been
a lot weirder 2001 s Jurassic Park 3
featured a low point in the whole
franchise with a dream sequence that
included a talking Raptor
despite that the producers wanted to
double down with human Dino hybrids for
a sequel yes Jurassic Park turns into
the island of dr. Moreau back in 2005
the proposed story for the fourth film
was a secret genetics lab that crossbred
humans with dinosaurs creating hybrids
capable of solving complex problems and
firing automatic weapons and probably
inspiring a lot of toys too
the idea got far enough along that a
script was written and concept art was
developed thankfully the human Dino
hybrids idea went extinct but don't get
too cozy after all to quote dr. Ian
Malcolm life finds away longtime
Ghostbusters buffs might already know
that a potential third entry in the
franchise would abound the blue-collar
gang taking a trip down to the
underworld to visit Satan's homestead
the name of this film is going to be
ghostbusters 3 hell-bent though it's
version of hell would not feature your
standard lake of fire and molten
brimstone the idea was that hell was
actually an alternate version of
Manhattan called Mann Hilton where the
crew would even meet up with the devil
himself a Donald Trump like character
named mr. sniffler while the
Ghostbusters in Hell pitch is well known
what's less well known is that the idea
actually goes back much further to the
first film in early drafts of the story
the Ghostbusters made it to the gates of
Hell which were even designed by concept
artists and comic book legend Bernie
Wrightson he elaborated on the
experience in a 2016 Kickstarter video
so I did a lot of drawings of of those
which you never made it I don't think
they even filmed you know but you know
there made it to the final movie the
original pitch for a third indie film
before Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade was finalized was as crazy as
its title Indiana Jones and the Monkey
King the story was conceived by three of
the greatest blockbuster minds ever
Steven Spielberg George Lucas and Home
Alone director Chris Columbus Columbus
was hired to pen the script which begins
with Indy fighting a ghost in Scotland
Indian friends are seeking the mythical
city of The Monkey King who's enchanted
orchard contains fruit that will grant
eternal life in typical indie movie
fashion he must fight Nazis along the
way in not so typical fashion the Nazis
have machine gun arms and Indy saved by
tank driving gorillas Indy even rides a
rhinoceros it's pretty intense
despite everything he survived before in
this film Indiana Jones actually dies
temporarily because he's pure apart
Cindy's brought back to life by the
magical fruit - The Monkey King
considering how insane the entire
project sounds we might have to consider
ourselves lucky that we got Indiana
Jones in the Crystal Skull instead well
maybe not Will Smith's star power
carried I am Legend to become the
biggest hit of the 2007 holiday season
nothing says holly-jolly family fun like
the last man on earth battling an undead
army given that the film made Bank
Warner Brothers naturally wanted a
sequel with Smith starring there was one
problem Will Smith's character dies at
the end of the film not to be deterred
by a little thing like the main
character being dead WB proceeded onward
the first solution was to make a prequel
because I am Legend was about the human
population being wiped out due to a
zombie infection the prequel would find
Smith's lone survivor dr. Neville just
before the world ended another option
was floated for a sequel that would have
found Smith's character returning as a
clone fortunately I am Legend two never
got past the planning stage
so the original remains a legend despite
the huge success of 1977's Close
Encounters of the Third Kind director
Steven Spielberg refused to make a
sequel he offered up an alternative
though a film that makes the horror of
Jaws with the extraterrestrials of Close
Encounters the film was ultimately
abandoned though elements of it remained
in et the extra-terrestrial which
presents a much kinder gentler alien
the film was a similarly huge success
and Universal wanted a sequel
surprisingly Spielberg was on board for
this one
he and ET screenwriter Melissa Mathison
penned a treatment that had that lovable
little guy ET being part of a warring
alien race whose evil albino members
have imprisoned other alien races from
across the galaxy for food yes that's
exactly what Spielberg planned for et to
nocturnal fears now et isn't all
sunshine unicorns and rainbows it's
actually a compelling examination of the
effect of divorce on a family but still
carnivorous mutant ETS that sounds like
a completely different franchise David
Fincher's dark serial-killer film 7
wowed audiences and critics alike
unsurprisingly the studio wanted a
sequel also unsurprisingly the sequel
would have been titled 8 with the number
8 replacing the Jeep unlike I am Legend
which wanted to undo the ending of the
previous film 8 was content with leaving
Brad Pitt's character in prison don't
assume this means the sequel wasn't
going to be ridiculous far from it
in eighth Morgan Freeman's world weary
detective continues to hunt serial
killers but discovers he has the ability
to predict the future
this concept got far enough along that a
script was actually written you don't
need to be able to see the future to
know that this would have been a very
bad idea a sequel to 7 isn't bad in
theory but giving Freeman's supernatural
abilities is ludicrous while the sequel
never happened the story actually did
much of the screenplay was repurposed
for 2015 solace a movie about a psychic
solving crimes starring Colin Farrell
and Anthony Hopkins
despite the talent attached solace Baum
so we don't have to worry about anyone
trying to make 9 to be fair describing
Forrest Gump's plot makes it sound kinda
nuts Tom Hanks plays a man with a 75 IQ
who experiences almost every momentous
event in American history between 1950
and 1981 from teaching Elvis to dance to
calling the police
in Watergate still it worked enough that
at one Best Picture and got Tom Hanks
his second Oscar for Best Actor even
with that primer Forest Gump
- sounds genuinely insane where to begin
well Forrest goes broke and plays for
the New Orleans Saints he invents the
formula for New Coke and also creates a
power plant fueled by pig poo he crashes
the Exxon Valdez rides in the back of a
J's Bronco and works for NASA there he
befriends an orangutan named sue who
joins him in Operation Desert Storm
while the first film managed to
seamlessly weave this one man throughout
American history the proposed sequel did
so with all the subtlety of Lieutenant
Dan hosting a children's show the whole
thing just sounds awkward that's all I
had to say about that since coming home
from Vietnam John Rambo has battled
Vietnamese forces Soviet soldiers the
Burmese army and even some Americans
with that line of a victories what enemy
is left for the one-man army to take
down well Rambo v was originally set to
pit Sylvester Stallone super soldier
against the half-man half-beast pure
killing machine
Rambo v the savage hunt would have seen
Rambo sent to the Pacific Northwest to
clean up the mess after a top-secret
government experiments creates an
out-of-control monster Stallone
clarified the movie's planned plot in
2009 it's not a universal soldier it's
not me fighting a super soldier it's
actually a feral beast it's this
amalgamation of fury and intelligence
and pure unadulterated range
Rambo's going against the feral beast
that has absolute cunning and
intelligence and a will to survive that
is only matched by Rambo's this might be
the one sequel on this list that we
almost wish did happen alas Rambo 5 the
savage hunt was abandoned in favor of
the upcoming Rambo 5 which sees Stallone
fighting the Mexican cartel instead
maybe just maybe it'll do well enough to
make Rambo vs monster happen
fingers crossed a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away George Lucas made
plans for a Star Wars sequel that wasn't
part of his original vision before the
movie that would eventually be
called a new hope was released Lucas
gave partial creative control of his
space opera to writer Alan Dean Foster
Foster was hired in 1976 depende the
novelization of Star Wars as well as a
second book which Lucas could use for a
potential follow-up that book was the
first official Star Wars sequel Star
Wars splinter of the mind's eye Lucas's
only restriction was that the story
could be filmed on a low budget so he
could reuse props and sets splinter
finds Luke Leia c-3po and r2d2 stranded
on a dark foggy mining world which
contains a powerful crystal sought by
the Empire Vader shows up only briefly
for the grand finale fight while Han and
Chewie don't show up at all as Harrison
Ford was only contracted for one Star
Wars splinter is a cool idea but was
basically Lucas's back-up plan in case
Star Wars only did so so of course it
became the highest-grossing film of all
time at that point
launching arguably the most popular
franchise in history and allowing Lucas
to film his saga as he had planned it
from the start what is it with sequels
to movies where the main character dies
while gladiator may not have aged well
Ridley Scott's 2000 swords and sandals
epic took home Best Picture and box
office gold Russell Crowe also won Best
Actor for his performance as Maximus
Decimus Meridius his crowning moment in
a career that has been spotty at times
one of those spotty times was in the mid
to late 2000s after the biggest bomb of
his and Ridley Scott's respective
careers 2006 is a good year perhaps
hoping to revive past glory Crowe wanted
to be in a gladiator sequel despite
Maximus dying at the end of the film the
solution just throw some Roman mythology
on it Scott's and Crowe hired Australian
musician and screenwriter Nick Cave to
come up with a creative solution to
bring back Maximus caves gladiator - had
Maximus melding with Roman gods to
achieve immortality he is then
reincarnated on earth where he defends
the early Christians and goes on to
fight in various conflicts including
world war ii and the vietnam war
eventually rising through the ranks of
the modern-day pentagon the film might
not have been good
it definitely sounds entertaining a ham
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stop are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one